yeah I've reached out to Andrew Santino
um I don't know how many times too many
um and uh every time I asked can can you
do my podcast I'll bring it to you it'll
be so easy um it was
uh man I got too much going on uh like
and it got to a point where I was so
frustrated that I lashed out in the most
humiliating way it was very funny yeah
put you should put the text up on the we
should make t-shirts of what he said to
you [__] you
bro and I legitimately was like is this
for real immediately it's a comic you're
like this is a bit he's doing a bit and
I was about to go [__] you
bro and I'm like no no he's mad I could
tell I was like no he's actually
frustrated my favorite part about that
whole thing is he said eat [__] eat
[__] typing so fast I misspelled each
[__] sh your anger restricts you from
actually getting the the disc out eat
[__] eat [__] and then you said yeah I'm
going to go eat [__] yeah I'll go e some
[__] I can feel my face getting red um
but here's the thing I've never heard
Steve talk like that in my life that's
why when he when he was like dude I was
like bro let's let's get out of here
let's go somewhere it as is often the
case it had nothing to do with with you
no I knew that like I was uh I've been a
comic for 20 years like I get it by now
when when when when I fight with Bobby
when when I get into it with any friends
in our world I know right away what's
really going on it's some other [__]
you're fried it's a relationship you're
tired it's family [__] it's dude it's
always everything else I bur and I Burr
one
time Burr one time and I had a little
thing and it wasn't a big deal but I was
bummed I was like really hurt because I
look up to him I respect him like he's a
hero oh yeah and then he something
happened it's noow one's business but it
was like it bummed me out and then a
couple days later he texted me because
he's like the greatest dude on Earth and
was like I'm sorry man I didn't I don't
know why I said that I don't know why
this went this way but he was like
straight up it's you know it's because
of XYZ and explained to me like what was
going on I was like all good I got it I
didn't take it as me me I knew some
other [__] was up and he was like that
had nothing to do with you but for some
reason you were [__] in the line of
fire and you got clipped and I was like
it happened dude I let that stuff go so
fast dudee it goes away it's like my D I
grew up in a world of lies and Chaos of
my dad was a drug addict and out of
prison who never showed up but said he
was going to show up so I always know
about the other side of it where you're
like something else is going on
fortunately I had but you showed up to
for for today for me dad you were here
fortunately I I uh I came around pretty
quickly and and no you did it was good
and and I acknowledged where I had come
up short yeah but did your dad ever tell
you to eat [__] he would he would finish
it he'd say eat [__] I I uh I was typing
so fast and and I wrote eat sh h i y i I
misspelled it and just it was already
sent each each ey is kind of a cool and
then he sent it again yeah oh I
misspelled it each twice yeah
yeah yeah do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is steo butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and sto's butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude